il ya une grande confusion au sujet du
terme
électronique sert que pour la grande
masse du public electronics et
l'aspirateur c'est la machine à laver
alors qu'en fait c'est pas la musique et
électroniques mais plutôt l'énergie des
instruments et on va le voir l'énergie
des instruments qui est électronique se
taire c'est un petit peu comme si on
définisse elle aime la musique classique
comme de la musique mécanique puisque
finalement les violons les pianos les
orgues sont les instruments mécaniques
le premier groupe allemand c'est que
j'utilise tout ça en fait d'une façon
assez intellectuelle je veux dire par là
qu'il faut un petit peu ils se disent à
la machine pour la machine c'est un
petit peu l'apologie de la machine et
c'est peut-être un petit peu en
tempérament allemand fin oui mais ça
bien sûr c'est un homme normal mais je
vois là bas quelque chose qui ressemble
plus
un terminal d'ordinateurs quinquin piano
par exemple il a effectivement tu as
raison il ya des cartes perforées
exactement comme un ordinateur c'est un
petit ordinateur exactement on peut
vraiment employer le terme
et effectivement on peut enfoncer la
carte comme ça dans l'instrument skip ce
qui ressemble de prime abord plus
effectivement à quelque chose un
ordinateur qu'un cas un instrument de
musique rôle de la carte perforée cette
fois pas le rôle la carte perforée c'est
c'est alors que par exemple dans un
piano dans une guitare tu as un
1 1 sont bien déterminés là ici c'est
toi qui crée ton propre son alors je
veux tu as comme ça avec cet instrument
a tu as mis le piano une fois ça sera à
son piano une fois ce sera un son de
pluie une fois son brouillard une fois
un son de locomotive avec mais le le
rôle du compositeur reste exactement le
même
en fait ça c'est un instrument c'est un
autre conducteur mais alors que celui là
que le celui qu'on vient de voir était
beaucoup plus un instrument pour tous
qui êtes harmonique
ça c'est un conducteur plus plus
rythmique s'étaient toutes les petites
lampes que vous voyez ici correspondent
à des sonorités bien précise qu on peut
programmer à l'avancé par exemple voyez
je peux par exemple effacer une ligne et
je compose exactement le rythme que je
veux par exemple en mettant des noirs
des blanches décrochent des doubles
croches suivant la vitesse qu'on utilise
ici et ensuite j'ai plus qu'à faire
démarrer sa l'homme laddh dans le
compositeur est ce qu'il est vraiment
utile et le rôle reste exactement le
même je pense que tous les instruments
qu'on fabrique sont un petit peu comme
comme tout ça c'est un petit peu le
reflet de sont même complètement le
reflet de l'intelligence humaine
j'ai dit tout à l'heure tu avais 29 ans
je sais même que tu as fait des débuts à
l'opéra que tu as fait un stage de trois
années au service de la recherche moyens
et sa formation musicale qu'est ce que
c'était un saint avant ça j'ai fait des
j'ai fait des études classiques normal
ensuite je suis j'ai terminé le
conservatoire je suis passé au centre de
recherche musicale effectivement de
leurs tf
pendant trois ans et jean michel c'est
avec toi que la musique électronique est
montée sur la scène de l'opéra
oui ça c'est un très bon souvenir à la
suite de quand j'ai quitté le groupe de
recherche je suis
et
j'ai fait j'ai commencé là où les
compositeurs termine en général c'est à
dire j'ai fait j'ai fait rentrer la
musique électronique à l'opéra et c'est
un très bon souvenir on m'a fait même
peindre les hauts parleurs en aurait
pour aller avec le décor partout on est
bien loin de ce que tu vois ici
[Musique]